what you're about to watch is a special
private training session for people who
bought a copy of my book built to serve
enjoy
okay so what was our topic how to
manifest the power of belief through
visualization and positive thinking to
achieve something great or seemingly
impossible
so
that's an interesting one i don't uh
i don't use a ton of visualization
in my
day-to-day
um positive thinking i think that i
think the best thing if you want more
believe is just to
have the environment around it
right i just came off a pocket like just
before this i was talking to a woman
and we're talking about
courage
her who was courage so going through who
i helped process or who was courage
she's built a successful business
you know wants to have a bigger impact
okay it's going to be by injecting
people with more courage uh
and she said well what do i do when i
get stuck
you know like when i get stuck on what
to do i don't know what my next step is
i get scared like well is the problem
that you don't have you don't know the
how or is the problem that you're just
actually lacking courage
it's like you know what i'm just
not like i don't have the courage
so we get we get in our own way we feel
a lot of times that it's the how but we
talked about um
sasha fierce
is beyonce's alter ego
so
when beyonce needs to summon
her best most bold most courageous self
she she becomes somebody else she named
it
no sasha fierce
is that right xan
yeah sasha fierce
so she becomes somebody else to go do
the thing
that she was afraid to do
and so i think a lot of times you get
caught up on the how when the problem is
really you're just not in tune with who
you actually are
because if you're showing up as your
most courageous self
you can conquer anyhow the how now is
not you suddenly feel unstuck
so how do you get more belief how do you
manifest belief i think you need to be
around believe more
you know like if it's my content then
then there's
20 videos three videos a day that we
upload across our channel so it's no
shortage you can have it on repeat on
loops and you'll never have to hear the
same video again because there's so much
content going up but whatever else is
the thing that helps you feel that way
whether that's other podcasts or humans
actual humans in your life or videos or
shows or books or podcasts or coaches
whatever whoever makes you feel that way
be around that more often
and then you'll start to be it
think about your actual my office is
designed with intent
this tells a story i believe these
pictures the things on the wall the
outfit that i wear you know i'm i'm i'm
captain america showing up for work he
got zane with his captain america shield
behind him
uh i think all of that matters i i would
say more superman but okay
yeah
oh i'm superman okay
you're captain america great like i'm i
feel like a superhero putting this on
like it's part of the ritual and putting
this on and that might sound silly or
stupid or crazy whatever that doesn't
matter what you have to do it's it makes
me believe more on myself you know if if
meditating naked on the balcony with
your cat is the thing that helps you
feel believe then go do that like
awesome no judgment
uh
and so i think i think the routines you
have as well as what you're injecting
into your environment both like this is
a physical environment right the walls
behind me that that's possible to change
i'm not changing that every day
but then there's the habitual things
that we do that impact our environment
the clothes i wear is a habit the videos
i create and i watch is a habit the
rooms i show up to is a habit hiring a
coach is a habit right like all these
things are the habits we have that then
can inject more that belief so whoever
is
saying it in the way that resonates with
you
that's what you need more of in your
life and that may change you know next
year you may need somebody else
i'd like to say that oprah and eric
thomas have the same message right oprah
hugs you and eric thomas yells at you
but it's the same message and some days
you may need more of the hug and some
days you may need more of the yell or
the push
great like no judgment take what you
need as long as you get more of that
belief so i think that's way for me at
least more important than
visualizing like i don't visualize
myself
having 10 million subscribers or
whatever the next
goal is
um but i know that as long as i'm
around the people who are challenging me
to believe more myself great things will
happen
so i don't know if that answers the
question but that's at least my take on
it
uh
thank you for jose for asking it so
what do you guys got how can i help how
can i serve what's on your mind evan i
have a question that kind of
plays off of what you were talking about
and movement makers today okay
so
i actually i'm not doing interviews yeah
like i'm not interviewing anybody
um i'm not ready for that i don't have
time for that and i've still got little
ones around the house for at least
another year
um
but i'm doing a lot of interviews so i'm
being interviewed i've done
two dozen i don't know close to 30 maybe
since
february
nice um thank you
and i i'm noticing
that like my message is changing because
i'm changing so like every time i learn
something new my message shifts a little
bit so i was taking all the information
basically that you were giving out this
morning to make me a better interviewee
versus
a better interviewer
um and also helping to kind of guide
those people that um
are new to interviewing because i've
definitely noticed a difference between
people who are brand new and people who
are kind of experienced
because i'm a lot of times i'm spending
45 minutes just talking about my life
and i it's
i feel like i'm just like going on and
on and on
so my question is is i was thinking
about
doing like a bulleted list of kind of
like important points
um
that i think will be good to talk about
to kind of keep myself on track
and i'm wondering how
you see how to praise the question like
how do i best
kind of tie in my overall message with
like the new stuff that i'm learning
but also i guess tailor it to the person
who's interviewing me or not
interviewing me as the case may be
yeah does that make sense yeah yeah i uh
that actually could be a really cool
follow-up session for movement makers is
how to be a really good interviewee
this is a lot that we can cover there as
well that i mean the question was from
the interviewer side but there's a lot
we can go over how to be interviewee as
well which i think would be helpful for
movie maker so
file that away if you guys want to vote
on that topic for for next time around
zane's like shaking his head like okay
maybe i'll vote on that
um
i would not give them a list of topics
to talk about
because then you're gonna easily default
back into your usual stories
and that's not great for them for their
show and it's also not great for you
because
now you're just saying the same stuff
you're not learning you're not being
challenged you're not growing
uh so
hopefully they've done some kind of
research or they're interested in in you
for some reason
for the beginner stuff
turn it into a coaching session for them
even though they didn't ask
and the easiest way to do that is ask
why are you interested in that
she's like bonnie
how did you get started or whatever like
why why is that so important
and then they're gonna say some kind of
story and then you tie that into like
your message is still to be unbreakable
right
there's so many ways to help people be
unbreakable
and you should my stories have changed
hopefully like if i send the exact same
stories that i said eight years ago
that's not cool
there's not a lot of growth there
there's still some like okay my origin
story and
you know most painful moment in my life
etc those will still pop up but i like
the challenge
of sharing new stuff
you know the
in movie makers today i could have
talked about the tony robbins interview
that i did
three or four years ago like my first
one that got me really nervous but i've
told that story so many times so i'm
going to talk about the matthew
mcconaughey one
so it took me more time to go and
prepare that i had to go find the quotes
and put the pictures together and that
took more time than i could have just re
recycled the same story and most of you
guys probably haven't even heard the
tony robbins story
but
i want to challenge myself
i like the fun so if somebody's coming
to you and they're really new you might
have to take charge of the conversation
um even if they're not new like i went
to go to i talked about jordan belfort
when i went to his wolf of wall street
podcast
so
he's based in california they wanted me
to come for
almost a year like his team reached out
hey evan we want to do your show we want
you on our show can you come to the show
um
but it has to be in person
it's okay well i don't know the next
time i'm in california i can let you
know and so when i was there i did my
tour and i did a stop there when we
finally made it happen but it'd been
almost a year
and when i showed up there
whenever i show up to interview it's
like i don't know what's going to happen
okay let's go i mean i know of jordan
belford i watched some of his top 10
videos that we made on him just so i had
contacts but then he just starts asking
a bunch of
like he he had done no research on me i
don't think
[Laughter]
so he didn't know anything right about
me and that's i think part of his style
is he just wants to just
hang loose and see what happens so he's
asking me questions about my early
career and all this stuff and i i just
started to feel like
okay this this thing is going nowhere
like i don't know where what the point
of this is happening like what are we
doing so then i flipped it just started
talking about youtube and started
critiquing his channel
and it turned from that 25 minute
interview to an hour and a half and him
rushing to get to the next thing and
calling his son up because i started
coaching him on his channel like i took
control of that conversation i have to
do that a lot with smaller
shows because
one they're just getting started i might
be their first guest i like being
people's first guest and two they're
also sometimes a little intimidated in
that
oh my god i've been watching your
content for eight years and you changed
my life and i can't believe i'm having
this moment and like they can't control
themselves so i need to often take
control but but it can happen with
bigger people as well um so you're
thinking okay how can i actually serve
this person how can i help them
and so you can't if you don't know much
about them so you asked about them
so you ask why is this question they ask
you a question
that you've answered a million times
why
let me ask you something first why is
that question so important to you like i
said bonnie what would you tell your
younger self
that's a great question but let me ask
you first why that's your first question
like what is the answer how's that going
to help you
and then they're going to answer
hopefully they'll they should play ball
and then you
take the interview off course you've
seen that in the in the
the gaming channel when we do the live
streams a whole bunch of times and
people ask a question
especially definition questions that's
one that always
gets me
like what's your definition of an
entrepreneur say okay but why is that
your question why do you care about the
like how does the answer to that help
you with anything and then that leads to
a better question
so you can guide people by asking why
they care so much about the answer to
that question
i would do that instead of
um giving them a list of topics to say
here are eight things that i know how to
talk about
i think you'll get it
i i just find like i said now that i'm
doing like one two three of these a week
like now people
are doing pre-interview interviews which
is honestly and this sounds maybe crappy
but it's driving me crazy because i'm
like i'm more or like i like the organic
conversation i like that i know i don't
we don't do them i don't do
pre-interview interviews
and then they're asking me they want my
bio which i totally understand
but they're not it's like they're being
lazy and it's
i i'm just being honest because i know
you can help me but it's like they're
being lazy they don't know who i am and
i have bios everywhere
like the app that i'm using is called
matchmaker.fm and it's literally just
for podcast guests and hosts and i'm
like
i wrote a one page everything you need
to know about me saying and this one guy
literally asked me to send him eight
bullet points today and i'm going what
are you supposed to do look i'm supposed
to show up and answer questions and help
you
like i'm doing all i'm doing your job i
feel like and again i know that sounds
maybe like i'm still getting started and
maybe that sounds kind of conceited but
at the same time it's like
why am i even coming on your show if you
don't know anything about me and aren't
really interested in what i have to say
it's setting up boundaries and you're
letting it happen
right so yeah i did and this is like the
third one and i'm like i don't want to
do this anymore great yeah and i
couldn't
our second one
so i i would have for me i love video so
i have a video that explains what to
expect in an interview with me
and i'll say a lot of the things that we
talked about today
it'll be don't read my bio i don't care
if you read my bio tell me why you know
why i'm here
just introduce me as however you want i
don't care if you missed something um
don't even introduce me and do the
introduction after before afterwards and
let's just dive into the content ask me
the question you care the most about
yourself as a human that you want help
with and i and i my assistant sends out
that video but you could make a quick
video explaining what it's like to work
with you and anytime they
write back can you give me eight bullet
points or whatever you say hey here's
here's my video about
how
how i like to work that i think we find
valuable and in there you can address
content it's like as far as the content
goes
here's here's a link to my story
ask me anything you want about it
uh i don't
or otherwise i'm open like whatever the
theme of your show is i want to spread
a mission of being unbreakable
how can i use that to serve you
you know i'm happy to go anywhere i'll
go anywhere i may not have an answer
like people don't ask me about gardening
or something because i you know nina and
nina would know really well but not me
or djing right i mean people don't
although i have done a lot of salsa
djing but in general people aren't
asking me about that kind of stuff so
they tend to stick inside the wheelhouse
wheel house but if i'm
on a service like that
you're gonna just like if you're on a
matchmaking
website for dating you have people just
sending you like hey
you know want to hook up he's like no
[Laughter]
so you don't want those people
right so you have your video you teach
people that they don't watch it or they
don't care then you move on because they
haven't taken the time to look at how to
work with you so fenan's about to ask
you a question i want fernando to know
you think i'm nice evan is super super
nice he's a wealth of knowledge and
information so don't hold back he's
super sympathetic and he's super
understanding so so don't be nervous
fernando this is evan carmichael he's
the he's the coolest guy all right let's
go fernando what do we got right yeah uh
so
i have difficulty identifying my
personal purpose my one word okay
i followed the exercise and the book i
listed 46
i'm really finding it hard to narrow it
down my background is
i've been always good at obeying
and uh
maybe zayn was right that i may have the
disease to please
i came from
being a missionary for seven years when
i opted out during a living i moved to a
non-profit and supported their cause
ever since my purpose was always behind
the organization's goal
but now that i'm doing something for
myself
and
it's just now that i
finally sit down and
think of
what value do i really what value what
are my core values really
i'm having a hard time and identifying
and yeah
what were the four that you came up with
it's 46
46
yeah all right okay so now okay if you
have that many then you have to start
grouping them so the next step is
there's going to be a bunch that fall
into similar buckets
so you got to get them into buckets so
like inspiration and motivation are two
different words but they're in the same
kind of bucket
so that becomes the next job zayn did
you already do the one-on-one with him
no yeah okay you should definitely do it
i read your lips i read your mind okay
you should okay you should definitely do
you get a free one-on-one with zen
anyway if you bought the book
so you're here uh
but you should do that before you meet
zayn
try to get it down to five
buckets so you take those 46 and you're
putting nine or ten
inside different buckets
all right so you're categorizing them
and don't worry about them being perfect
like inspiration motivation whatever
they're close enough to the same thing
so
you know um
if you're a missionary maybe you have
faith as one of the words or maybe you
know jesus or god or whoever right i
mean those it's all in the same bucket
that's one bucket so make your five
buckets
spend time categorizing them
and then when you talk to zane he can
help you narrow it down to the one most
important one and then dan this is
classic like
one word and then credo right the who
and then credo so
we'll show you how to actually make them
all fit
but if i asked you what are the 46 the
problem is if i asked you what are the
46 you wouldn't know
there's just too many you can't you
don't memorize them so if you haven't
memorized them then you're not living
them
where if i'm
believe and bonnie is uh unbreakable and
zayn is confident it's a lot easier to
remember it and when you remember it
you're more likely to live it
right
so that's what we need to get you to do
is to take those 46 that's that's
actually the hardest part just
identifying the list is the hardest part
so that's great you've already done the
hard work it may not feel like it but
that's the hardest part now it's just
categorizing them
you're five
and then zayn will help you go
turn that into one plus three
underneath
all right
should i focus on
uh what i have always been
as people see me or
uh
so the values are are evergreen like
they live forever that they're what you
have been and what you continue to want
to be
like believe is what i've always wanted
to be
it's what the questions are like what
did you love about your parents and who
was your favorite teacher growing up and
why and what kind of music do you like
and why you know if you think about your
favorite teacher
who was your favorite teacher did you
answer that one
my history teacher in third year high
school he was really
weird but uh confident guy okay well
here so so it's not because he taught
you history
right
because he made you feel
something he made you a better person
somehow
wasn't the content it was how he made
you feel about yourself so
you know what did he make you feel he
made you feel more confident
he made you feel it's okay to be weird
what else did he make you feel
yeah now that you've said it i think
yeah there might be something i didn't i
did not see it that way when i answered
that question
well that's
you know we're doing it right now so
what's one more he made you feel
confident he made you feel okay to be
weird and what else
uh
[Music]
yeah he made
it
he made it he made me feel that it's
okay to be weird uh
confidently tell that what he does and
really does it well
okay so he was competent
he was competent in his work so
confidence
competent and okay to be weird
that's him
so here's the thing
fernando
what do you still need now you still
need to be more confident you still need
to be more competent and you still need
to believe that it's okay to be weird
right
and listen all of us do too i need to be
more confident more confident and
embrace my weirdness more as well too
right and everybody on the call the
exact same thing
so those are
those some of the values right it's not
because he taught you about how
the civil war happened or you know
whatever right it's not the history
class that he taught you is he taught
you how to be a better human with these
three things so you repeat that exercise
for
the five essential questions that are in
the book that was one of them but your
favorite movie what do you love about
your parents etc and you'll get a list
but then you can start the bucket
right you can start to create categories
and then you take that to zan and he'll
help you turn it into your who and your
credo and then that gives you a lot more
guidance
because if you come down to something
like it's okay to be weird like say that
was your core at the top
now it's now you have to get a lot
weirder you know like now fernando's got
to really embrace some inner weird right
and that could be the ultimate
talking about escaping a life of you've
only worked for other organizations
and taking on their mission whether it's
a missionary or another
organization
a lot of them don't allow you to be
weird because you just have to show up
and do the thing that they tell you to
do
now you got to go find your own thing
and embrace your weirdness so maybe
that's what you land on but maybe it's
confidence maybe it's competence maybe
it's something else
but what we find then
that's going to be for the rest of your
life
it's like you're gonna be 95 years old
fernando
being the weird guy
you know dancing on the street
[Laughter]
because you
just spent the past few decades
embracing your weirdness
right
that'll be the best of who you are
um so that's why it's a really valuable
exercise
so see it through that lens
maybe now it's not 46 anymore maybe you
narrow it down or maybe maybe you maybe
becomes 146 now
you know
however it works it doesn't matter
that's fine like having a big list is
better than having no list
right the first edit of built to serve
was bigger than the final edit like just
getting it out is the most important
thing and then editing down is a lot
easier to get it down to your four or
five buckets
um
that's exciting man you're in you're in
for a wild ride you're gonna have a lot
of fun with zen too i told you he was
good
who's got a question a problem something
i can help with who wants to go first
what do you got for me today so i got to
a really big aha moment and my question
is um understanding someone else's who
um and especially parents uh
kind of on the on the same stream of
thought from last week when we were
talking about obstacles and how becoming
the teacher or becoming the parent with
your own parents and setting business
hours
um
thinking about their who and
how to talk to their who versus mine and
i'm still learning mine
my who i have five different hashtags
and i'm still trying to figure out my
who and i'm sleeping on it and waking up
and i think um
my who is changing
and i'm gonna just start off with this i
have uh
adventure as my who okay
and
because i have a lot of energy and every
time i think of happiness it's more of
adventurous it's more of a more
adventurous with everything
and then
my credo which i'm finishing up
i have
discipline
i have
compassion
and i have
energy
and it changes every combination okay
wait so
what's changing is the adventure at the
top changing of the three underneath
that are changing it feels like the
three underneath are changing okay i i
invested in
a years ago um a trademarked my name
laura explora
and because i'm an explorer and i'm an
adventure and everything i do it really
comes down to that when i wake up every
morning that's what it is
and so
that for me is a no-brainer it's more of
it's more of adventure than explore i'm
more like
i'm more optimistic and adventurous
versus just explore
but the three
pieces of my credo keep changing
and i have words all
over the place and um
i think ubuntu
was a word because connection is very
big for me and i kept saying
connection is so as you can see
connection is so important to me that
it's if i don't have that nothing is
right in my life
so i have to kick one of the three out
and put connection or ubuntu because i
believe everything we're all connected
ubuntu is that what you're saying yeah
okay and if i understand it correctly
that that word means we're all
we're all connected everything is
everything is uh
together everything is connected that
word it's
together connectedness is everything to
me okay but it's but it's it does that
let's go with the top is it actually
everything or is adventure everything
there you go that's evan i
i don't know
i think it's everything i think ubuntu
is everything more than adventure i
think adventurous piece of the puzzle
okay
how do i know
this is a hard question this is not a
head question you don't know you feel
yeah
what feels the best
well nothing seems right unless
i'm connected
not in a codependent way
not and i can't be alone way but a
connection i thrive on that and i know
when i'm
feeling starved or um something's
missing it's because i'm missing that
big piece of the puzzle and once i get
it
i'm much better everything's much better
the example is last week
for me um connecting
was
a rocket ship for me with everything so
therefore
adventure
went down
and ubuntu connection connection how do
you spell ubuntu
i believe it's ub
u-n-t-o
t-u oh t-u okay i looked it up and it's
like it's a software company so then so
i gotta find it yeah then it'll come up
it's it's an
african word an african phrase i believe
and and someone should work with me one
time
and it resonated with me and it came up
out of nowhere
last night and i went oh that that's the
one well so here's something interesting
so i looked it up it says equality that
includes the essential human virtues
compassion and humanity
so we already have compassion showing up
as part of the definition
passion is already there
so we may not need that in our credo if
it already means compassion and
connection
so how do we get how do we get ubuntu
for you or ubuntu am i saying it right
ubuntu i think so okay so how do we get
that for you what is that what does that
mean to you if you had to think about
what what is underneath or how do you
get the connection
it has to be a good connection it has to
be a positive connection it has to be um
how do you get there how do you get to a
good connection what do you what do you
need to do like what think about the
children of
connection
so like adventure or exploring is
somewhere in there you get connected to
adventure
reaching out and serving people
connection
okay
it's an interesting
i feel like i'm on a quest
i'm always on an adventure to find
connection
and so therefore that's where i
that's good well like adventure and
quest are
our sisters right like they're pretty
close you could pick which one but it's
it's different than if you're if you're
going like adventure i get i get
connection or get ubuntu through
adventure i get ubuntu through serving
or service
yes and then you get it through
what's another way that you can get
connection or ubuntu for you
well i think an important part is also
self um
uh self connection
always
for sure yeah i mean i don't i don't
know that i did a good enough job
honestly in the book explaining that
part but whatever you come up with as
your who you need it for yourself
as well as what you give to the world so
i need more belief for myself yes always
it's a never-ending mountain that you're
climbing yes and you're trying to give
that to the world as well yes
so a hundred percent so self is already
built in so ubuntu for yourself and
ubuntu for the world right but how do we
and so how about this this discipline
fit in there or is it
i feel like
there's a discipline rituals um learning
focus um
i don't know i'm in the woods
but it's actually pretty close the grass
actually i think yeah yeah i like it
but look if i put it into i'm going to
put this into the chat here yeah for you
to read it but here's what i wrote down
so you got ubuntu at the top and then
you have adventure request and you have
service and you have discipline rituals
focused like those are all
uh
you could pick like take your choice
between adventure and quest they're
close it's it's basically the same thing
like one might mean something slightly
different cool like whatever you
resonate the most you said you like
adventure more than explorer right
it's still like the same thing it's the
same family it's close enough
with adventure cool i love it yes
service is number two cool and then
between
discipline ritual focus they're all in
the same category
so you pick which one feels the most
right to you like i can't tell you which
one this is a heart thing it's a laura
heart thing between the three of those
and you don't have to have the answer
right now but you know that whenever
you're you're lacking
happiness is because you don't have
connection
that's the number one to self yeah you
know connection and like but it also
means compassion right to self and then
or you feel like the work you're doing
is not connecting to other people and
there's no compassion for others right
but then how do you get it well we have
to go on an adventure or we have to go
on a quest yes it has to be something
that's fun and new and exciting not just
the same usual boring stuff especially
for you
like nobody likes photocopying their
same day over and over but especially
for you that's gonna be if it's the
lara's gonna do the same thing every day
you're gonna hate your life but i find
adventure in that like i see i seem to
find adventure in the mundane i can make
it fun this came from what do you love
best about your parents that they taught
you i had to think hard and it was oh my
god i can do anything and i can make it
fun
adventure yeah well but now instead of
only having it be like a coping
mechanism to help you get through the
boring we can seek out more adventure so
you have to be doing more bold more fun
more
big more new
if laura's the same person in a year
she's not going to be happy she has to
be doing something
and it's fine it's like part of your
thing is adventure request yes but then
that's not it it has to be service you
have to tie it to helping people it has
to be some kind of mission it's not just
a selfish thing for you
to go bungee jumping yeah adventure like
it's got to be tied into helping
somebody else somehow yeah
and then and then discipline ritual
focus somewhere and there that this is
this is planned out it's not just you
hope inspiration hits you
it's just like all over the place
creative artists it's like it's got to
have it's got to be factored in you need
your schedule it has to be focused yeah
so
that that all works and so whenever
you're not happy it's like it's one of
these three things that are leading all
of those things lead to ubuntu for you
and something in there is missing either
you don't have enough adventure you
don't feel like you're serving people or
or it's not focused or disciplined
enough that it's consistently happening
so you've got it i think you just need
to get a little more you're not in the
grass anymore i mean visually you are
might be but
it's really just down to between those
words what do you like what feels better
adventure request
or discipline rituals focus because
they're all like we're hitting the right
buckets just what do you want to name
the buckets so that it becomes more
clear but
that's amazing you've got it oh my
goodness evan that was this morning
because i i actually
thank you and i but i was actually
finding um
i was looking up hawaiian
words there are some hawaiian words that
actually mean
so much more than just the word where
it was it was hitting
um ubuntu is like there's uh
there's um oahu which is family um
connection
outside of like family of origin but
we're all family you know words like
that
um
even picking ubuntu as a word shows the
adventure quest side of you like no i'm
not picking a normal english word
well yeah i feel like i was almost close
to drawing a symbol because i couldn't
put my finger in the language
i'm seeing the experience but i can't
put my finger on what to call it but now
i'm getting closer yeah um okay wow this
is big for me it's
it was a solid week of
every challenge i think yay i think it's
i really uh
i went through a very big challenge over
the past week
an adventure actually i really looked at
it as a very intense adventure i'm like
oh
what do i like about this and how am i
approaching this and i believe it's
because i'm looking at it like an
adventure but i am having connection and
it's about connection and i'm gonna find
okay yeah and then like if we appeal
back so one i mean amazing we've got it
great you still have to narrow down like
you said adventure so much more than
quest it feels like adventure is more
the thing than quest but
you know between adventure and then
discipline rituals focus which of the
three just
names the bucket better
with all of these things
it's it's both kind of
attached to what we're currently doing
as well as new things we're seeking out
so
in the couple examples you've already
shared there's the coping mechanism of i
can turn
something that is mundane into an
adventure that's what i love about my
parents right cool there's also the oh
this is challenge in front of me but i'm
going to reframe it as an adventure
instead of a challenge right so like
whatever we're already doing we can
reframe it to feel
more connected to so this is actually an
adventure as opposed to something
challenging but it can also lead to new
so like how do we analyze our current
life but then also going forward if you
now have to plan out or think about
where you want to be doing for the next
12 months how can we
with discipline put some adventure into
our calendar as opposed just to reacting
to what we're currently experiencing
yes yes exactly
being responsible with the discipline
what you've currently got which is great
which will make you happier like same
thing if you took service your second
part of your credo yes you could take
the mundane
and if you can flip at the service
you'll show up differently yes you'll be
serviced as in uh share or teach or
sure yeah whatever it means to you but
like if you could take the thing if you
take something boring right now and you
found a way to be able to help somebody
else out through that thing you'll start
to feel more connected immediately to
the work that you're doing yes
that's that's so that's more of like a
coping mechanism reframing
as opposed to seeking out new things
that if you said i want to bring more
service to the world in the next year
what new things can i go off and
and create and put it into my schedule
so it becomes a focus or becomes a
discipline do you get the difference
you're going to see in a different way
so
go back to adventure for example right
so you're talking about the two coping
mechanisms you've been using are one
if it's born or mundane i can say it's
an adventure and then i'm i'm now i'm
good right
okay or this is so that's what you learn
from your parents there's this big
challenge in front of me it's an
obstacle i'm going to turn into an
adventure and so now i'm going to be
more inspired and motivated to go work
on it so you're flipping the current
situations yes into adventure so now
you're going to show up differently yes
right
so that but that's taking our current
life and just reframing it
yes towards adventure which is fine it's
it's a coping mechanism it's awesome
now instead of just taking our current
life and making it more adventure
what does building an adventure life
look like
going after this with discipline and
focus yes something that you're not
doing that you've never done before but
would be
fun to go on this new adventure a new
quest or new exploration
so it's injecting new into our
discipline and routine and focus as
opposed to just reacting to what we
currently have got it this is this is
adding
this formula
am i getting
okay so it's adding this formula to the
going forward not just the actual
present challenge yeah
right so
what are we going to add what's what's
new that we're going to create that's
going to lead to even more adventure so
with with intent we're going to create a
new adventure for ourselves going
forward
as opposed to just reacting to what we
currently have
as opposed to reaction
so you're asking me that question you're
asking well you don't have to have an
answer right away but it's like it's
just the thought process yeah that if
you had to with intention now to say
okay
i'm going to
over the next year i want to bring in
more adventure bringing more service
bringing more discipline and focus into
my life what does that life now look
like
that i'm creating for myself the people
i'm around the new things i'm signing up
and doing the the products i'm launching
the book i'm gonna write the speaking
gig that i'm gonna like whatever that
new adventure is that you want to go on
but it's something new that you're
creating as opposed to just reframing
what currently is
got it yes so that's the movement the
action for the movement yes um i'm
working on that right now i um
i i finally felt free enough to get to
that part after i figured this out
because because i was spending
89 percent of my time focused on the
challenge instead of
the challenge and then focus
90 of my time on what new can i create
um that's that was a real big shift for
me um
which is which is by reading um
uh i've gotten to that point which i
feel is huge
it's it it mean this is great i'll put
it again in the chat so you can see it
and everybody else can too but like that
is huge because if you're not happy
because you're not
you're not feeling in connection to
ubuntu which breaks down to adventure
service discipline
one of those areas have to be
hit stronger for you to feel more
connection right
and going forward
what can i do to create that being more
intentionable now designing a life what
is an intentional life around ubuntu
look like for you versus reaction to
this yes i get it i'm there i'm right
there all right we got it
not leaving you laura
but what a creation i got it yeah and
it's always both it's like reacting to
current life and creating new it's we
need
ubuntu believe for ourselves and what we
want to share with the world it's always
inwards and outwards yes and both oh i
love it evan thank you
cool well thanks for uh volunteering and
allowing us to deep dive and
you know again it's one of the things
like after you write the book you
realize oh i wish i talked about that a
little bit more so it was great that we
got a chance to go deeper here on this
call
oh maria's got her hand up what do we
got maria
hey evan good to see you
so i'm wondering um i've been learning a
lot about facebook reels and somebody i
i
respect said that it's like
really gaining momentum now
so what are your thoughts on facebook
reels
and and and can you i don't know if you
if you know can you do like a facebook
reel and then just upload it to
instagram or
i would go the other way around
instagram first and then to real so when
you're sharing a reel you have the
option to post to facebook like most of
the instagram stuff you have an option
to post to facebook as well
so
i i love the idea of repurposing content
if you're making content anyway just put
it everywhere um
if you care about twitter then the
easiest thing to do is do she's like i
don't know like 45 seconds
twitter the max is 45 seconds so if you
watch me in the morning i'll be walking
i walk outside every morning and i'm on
my believe walk and i'll make a quick
video about what today is gonna be all
about and i keep it the 45 seconds
because of twitter
the other ones are all a minute as your
max
vertical video but i'll do 45 seconds on
twitter share my thoughts of the day and
then i'll post to every platform
so um we'll actually keep it as a as a
story for instagram and facebook but it
could be a reel that you use instead i'm
reels are
super popular i'm i'm i'm in but i would
just take the real design for instagram
first
um or tick tock first either one and
then take it to the other platforms so
your reel goes to facebook it goes
instagram it goes to tic toc goes to
youtube shorts
so you can do that right after you make
the reel like
in your in your or do you have to
download it upload it yeah i'll usually
record it as a as a like a video on my
phone like an actual video video okay um
if you want to use any of the editing
features
inside any of the tools then
then you can upload it like you can
record it natively in those tools and
then download it and and put it to the
platforms but if you're going to make be
making content anyway might as well post
it to all the platforms if you don't
care about twitter then you have up to a
minute and you can put it i don't know
about twitter yet i'm like on the verge
of like overwhelmed with like that's
fine don't worry about it you know but
instagram and
facebook are so connected
that it makes sense to do that and then
um
yeah if you're i would i would put it on
tick tock and youtube as well but if
it's too overwhelming at the beginning
then don't stress about it like a lot of
these things is just building momentum
to the to the you know the new book you
just build momentum because at the
beginning it it takes a while to get
used to the thing that you're doing but
once you're doing it
it goes a lot faster you know like if
you're helping
if you're helping um
you know women deal with some of their
emotional baggage and issues like some
of the exercises that you give people
is overwhelming at the beginning and and
when you say you're going to make this a
new habit that that's
that's really hard at the beginning to
build that habit but once they get used
to it you know whatever you're asking
them to do on a daily basis once they
get used to it's like oh this actually
i'm getting used to it's not that hard
my first video took me two days to make
one video right
like
sitting down memorizing lines and now we
can like i'll bust out i recorded 20
videos yesterday right it's just a lot
easier
zayn saw like what zayn we recorded 10
videos in like an hour or something
they're an hour and a half in vegas
right i mean i was in vegas with zan a
couple of weeks ago or something and we
had a little bit of time said hey you
want to come to my hotel room and let's
film some videos and me drew and zayn
sat down and we just filmed some content
but that would have taken me so long to
do at the start of my career
and now it's just so much easier because
we've done it so
if you feel overwhelmed by everything
cool go go smaller just do
just do instagram facebook awesome
so you so you record it to your phone
and then when you do the really there's
a place to just put the reel up there
yeah you can do that or if you if you
like using some of the editing tools
inside instagram then you can use those
editing tools and then post
but again it's like not being so
overwhelmed by all the options and all
the tools and like
they give you a lot of options and they
can be really cool but it can also be
overwhelming and then you don't post
anything
right
yesterday on my instagram live we did
one with orlando who was been in
movement makers for over a year and uh
he hasn't posted content a long time
because it just said it was overthinking
so many like what do i call it and just
so many options that then nothing
happens
so
does it make sense strategically to put
it on every platform yes
but
not at the expense of not doing anything
yes so
if you if you find the tools too
overwhelming to even just post to
instagram reels cool don't don't worry
about the tools yet you'll get there
okay just focus on the message and then
once the message becomes easy and that's
routine then we can add another level
another level another level
great thanks so much evan yeah all right
cool
izumi's got our hand up where do we got
it zumi
hi evan and hi everyone i finally made
it i usually have class on thursday
afternoon so i can
it's hard for me to join but today's
open so i have a question i love it and
yeah or anyone can contribute or
give me ideas so
now that everyone's coming out we're
mixed you know talking and
i share my story what i do
and then i was like oh that's
interesting
and then
one mom said like i'd like to know
what's going to happen what you're going
to do
so we exchange
or i gave her my numbers and said oh
yeah we can connect on linkedin but
nothing happens and that's kind of has
been happening like some people are
interested in my story
when we meet in person
but i i have a hard time keep that
connection
through
social media or whatever it is
um
from your experience or anyone's
experience what's the best way to kind
of connect in
long term in social media emails or
so what i do i i usually suck at staying
in touch with people i'm really bad at
it i don't remember i'm i'm introverted
i don't have friends so it's like i
don't need the connection a lot like i
get i have mover makers i've you guys
this is amazing right i have i have this
group like that's where i get most of my
con as long as i have nina
then i'm good for for like in person
stuff but
but i realize how important it is for
business so what i do is every
i have a list of the top 100 people that
i want to stay in touch with
and i schedule in every friday
i'm looking at that list to see the last
time i checked in with them
and uh if it's been over three months i
find a way to reach back out and stay in
touch
and some of them are
some of the outreach is very basic
um
you know yesterday for example um i
don't know if you guys know alex from
mosey or not but he's another creator
and
we took a picture together at grow with
video live in vegas and i posted it to
my pinterest and when you post a
pinterest underneath it it says
uh other pictures that you might like
that are similar and underneath our
picture with all of these chris evans is
his name chris evans the captain america
guy
with the beard uh when he had the beard
um he doesn't have a beard in captain
america but he has he like had a bunch
of pictures with a beard so i take a
video of it and send it to alex say hey
alex i posted a picture to pinterest and
underneath is all of these captain
america pictures like i think uh i think
the world's telling us that you should
be a superhero right send it to him and
he sends it back like lol thank you for
this um so sometimes i do something fun
like that right and then i can i can
check on my list okay i messaged alex on
you know june 29th
and so if i haven't connected with alex
in the past three months since then then
i'll find someone something else to
reach out to alex about so sometimes
it's something fun like that sometimes
it's
what are they working on in their
business uh the easiest way to do is
look at what they're posting on
instagram what are they posting on on
instagram or twitter or tick tock
wherever they're most active what are
they posting and how can you react to it
how can you
i'll send a message hey congratulations
on x right or i love that post you did
like more than just a comment on their
on their post but i'll send them a
message and often a video message you
know like i probably sent you a video
message
um
walking outside in the park like hey
zoom me happy thursday you know just
something quick as a way just to stay in
touch with people
um
and i find that
super helpful so you make your list of
the 100 people who you've met who you
want to stay in touch with and then at
least every quarter if you want to make
it every month that's fine too
you find a way i hopefully they're
posting something like the more they're
actually posting content the the easier
it is but if they haven't posted
anything you can just say hey
julie i was thinking about you today
hope you're doing well
and just sending you lots of love give
me give me an update on where you're at
like it doesn't have to be a follow-up
yet to the thing that you talked about
but just as a way to stay in touch
my messages usually aren't the most
inspiring you know like when i'm walking
on the in the park
zooming how you doing happy thursday
sunny here in toronto sending you some
love thinking about you have a great
week believe sen right next but it's
like it's on my heart i'm thinking about
you but i i don't have anything
necessarily super inspiring to say but
it it just keeps you
top of mind so
um if you if you struggle at
like nina's great at that stuff just
naturally
my wife nina she'll just remember things
and she's like i wonder how you know
zan's doing we should we should send
zayn like oh yeah yeah it's a great idea
but i don't default to thinking that way
so i have to schedule it in and that
might seem more like cold and calculated
but it's love
i just don't remember uh so back to like
laura and discipline like i need more i
need discipline to do it or i won't do
it
um so that's what i would do like when
you meet people at an event or somebody
wants to hear more about your story
find a way to if you just get their
phone number cool that's great there's
nothing wrong with sending a text
message and saying hey i was thinking
about you
um send it as an audio so they can hear
they can hear your voice they send it as
a video so you can see your face
and if they're on social then
instagram dms are usually the the best
um that you can send videos or audios as
well as an easy way to stay in touch
okay
yeah i think that's the problem that
happened this past weekend was that i
only gave my number and i didn't get
hurt ah so
yeah it's like there you go i can i
can't even message her so what i love
doing there is i will if and i'm i i
suck at texting too and i forget to stay
in touch with people but when when
there's somebody who i'm messaging on
text and we exchange phone numbers i'll
i'll i'll send them a message but in
that message like okay what's your
number i'll send you a message right now
and then i'll i'll take a picture of us
like okay here hey send
so that they know who it's from
and so that i remember who they are and
like what we just did because i don't
remember names as well easily too so
like you see at the top like oh yeah
yeah yeah that's jason okay cool cool
cool that's how we met and so it's a fun
thing as well so i'll i'll send i'll
send you a text right now so i'll send
them the text and i'll take a picture
with us and they're smiling in it as
that reminder for both of us because
then they get some random number text
them like oh oh that's evan um so that's
a little hack that i use as well so yes
get their number
ask if they're on instagram or ask where
they post if they post content they may
not
you know like in this group everybody
should be posting content but um
if you're meeting people out in the wild
then they may not be posting um but yeah
that's an easy hack to get going
that's smart
thank you so much good luck kazumi
thanks for joining in if you want to get
a copy of build to serve and join us
live for our next training with me to
ask your questions you can go get the
book right there next to me right there
i'll see you there i'll see you to get
the book it's a good one much love